do you know how to cook rice
oh good question that's such an
interesting very good question um
i don't why don't you ask that but my
cooking show was about now
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah what kind of car
i know how to grow it
you okay me one grain of rice
yeah yeah and maybe five feet i can grow
ten thousand things of rice
that's how it's measured
i've got a funny story so we had
so i have all these kids and one time we
um we have babysitters and
we uh went to florida
to disney world and i was doing shows
and so we brought our babysitter
and she's from the philippines and we
were at the airport and we were they
were weighing our bags we're checking
them in and her bag was like 80 pounds
yes yeah and i was like uh
why is it 80 pounds i'm like well just
take whatever you got in there and put
it in this bag can i guess yeah
saxo rice and cans of spam yes well not
spam
but she had
i think it was
a 50 pound bag of rice and i was like
i was like we're gonna
we're gonna feed you
yeah yeah
and she was like i just you know it's
just like just a case
yeah i mean
no and i totally understand that because
when i go on the road with my family we
bring like let's say we're going to
joshua tree and my mom goes into a panic
because she's like i don't think they
have rice there or the kind of white
sticky rice that i like so what do we do
we bring the rice cooker and we bring
her calories i've never been to a city
where they didn't have [ __ ]
rice i know but the thing is
it was by the way it's like
it was sincere it wasn't like she was
like you know i gotta bring some [ __ ]
rice like
but i think it was like
it was a sincere thing like you know i
don't know i'm not all right i'm not
gonna have it yeah it's like it's like a
water insecurity because rice has eaten
breakfast lunch and dinner right yeah
it's you cannot have a meal without rice
okay why do you talk to me like i'm not
asian
i do the [ __ ] same thing yeah i know
you don't know how to cook rice i know
but yes i do oh those one cup don't you
i taught you one cup of rice one cup of
[ __ ] watermelon how did you learn
that what when did you learn that
yesterday from who
from who
you look men are dumb right we're dumb
we're very dumb yeah
and there's certain things
where i'm just like by the way when i
was i didn't own a coffee maker until i
was 30 because i thought they cost
hundreds of dollars
and people were like well why don't you
just get a coffee maker i'm like i don't
want to waste some money on they're like
it's 20 bucks yeah yeah i'm like really
so
i'm
so i don't know how your ratio was off
with the rice by the way what do you
mean a little bit more wine different
kinds of rice um
need different amounts of water
so the one that you were cooking
yesterday it's a little bit over one cup
of water you got it wrong you're a poor
student that's okay bobby how oh how um
if you don't mind me asking your age
this is a fun game yes will you guess
well first of all i will guess i will
guess your age and then i will add a
year